wenn bis zu 15 der lehrer nicht an die
schulen kommen muss ist auch automatisch
eigentlich heißen dass wieder
unterrichtsstunden ausfallen oder ja und
schon außerhalb würde ich jetzt nicht so
sagen ja haben ja immer gesagt wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass wir
präsenzunterricht gekoppelt haben mit
qualifizierten fernunterricht und die
lehrkräfte die jetzt nicht arbeiten
können die könnten aus unserer sicht
problemlos da in diesen qualifizierten
fernunterricht von zu hause aus
durchführen
denn das attest bedeutet jetzt hätte ich
nicht als jagd rang zehn findet dass ich
arbeiten können sondern es bedeutet vom
unter sehr dass ihr diese qualifizierten
unterricht zu hause durch das umsetzen
können oder ist eigentlich auch das
ergebnis dass wir so aus so dass das ja
auch passieren soll
das heißt fehlende lehrer bedeuten jetzt
nicht dass es probleme an den schulen
geben wird jetzt wenn ich sowas zu ende
gehen
das ist natürlich ein problem
lehrerversorgung grundsätzlich das ist
ja auch was wir seit jahren jetzt
endlich mitteilen dass wir der meinung
sind wir bilden zu wenig lehrkräfte aus
da gab es zwar in der kommission von der
kmk die letztendlich auch in der
offensive gestartet hat aber von
vornherein gerade ist die auch die zahl
der auszubildenden lehrkräfte nicht
ausreicht die studio gehen die band
zukünftig brauchen aufgrund der tatsache
dass sind nun die pandemie haben und
dieses problem eigentlich nochmal erneut
in einem brennglas dargestellt von gross
hat uns gezeigt wir wissen dass wir ganz
viele lehrkräfte braucht ja auch diesen
qualifizierten unterricht machen nur die
müssen darauf vorbereitet sein die
saison hat werden diese entsprechende
schulungsmaßnahmen kriegen müssen
das wäre ganz wichtig gewesen und das
muss man eher der politik an lassen als
den lehrkräften denn ich habe da sehr
viele gute beispiele gesehen dass
wirklich lehrkräfte engagiert gearbeitet
haben dann kam im nachgang leider die
datenschützer die natürlich auch recht
haben mit ihrer aussage dass da stehen
aber beide man unterstützung vor den
ministerien erhalten müssen mit welchen
instrumenten könnt ihr jetzt endlich mit
welchem programm könnt ihr letztendlich
den unterricht zu gestalten dass unsere
kinder nicht zum nachteil gereicht ist
das ganze sondern das wäre wenigstens
den unterricht sowie ein notwendig ja
auch entsprechend umsetzen will
das heißt der schulbeginn in zeiten von
corona steht noch immer vor einigen
problemen mecklenburg vorpommern jetzt
das erste bundesland nach und nach
kommen jetzt natürlich alle anderen auch
in ihren augen wie vorbereitet sind die
schulen jetzt also auf diese neue
normalität also ich denke bildung wird
weiblich in der tat immer mehr zum
glücksspiel
die vorbereitung sind sicherlich
gelaufen aber nicht in dem umfang wie
wir es uns gewünscht hätten
wir haben vor den sommerferien
eigentlich mit sehr guten start begonnen
und haben das vorbereitet wie es jetzt
endlich weitergehen sollte dass sie es
werden kleinere lerngruppen entsprechend
aufteilung nach schultagen dh die kinder
waren nicht jeden tag zur schule
das war guter ansatz aus unserer sicht
uns fehlen dann natürlich der kräfte ab
man hätte da durchaus mit studierenden
sprechen könnte das ganze unterstützt
hätten
und wir müssen natürlich sehen dass er
den digital park endlich nach vorne
treiben das förder und jain gibt wie
können die schulen sich entsprechend
aufstellen es gibt auch da sehr gute
beispiel die bereits vor dem gepackt das
gemacht haben aber leider hat sich da in
den letzten bord sehr sehr wenig getan
von daher freuen wir uns dass der
präsenzunterricht jetzt losgeht haben
aber auch sehr sehr großes bauchweh
dabei